Madonna living her best life and
clapping back at critics this ticks and
Stones can break my bones but names can
never hurt me the Queen of Pop made an
appearance at the grammy Sunday night to
introduce Sam Smith and Kim Petrus are
you ready for a little controversy
Anna how good is it to be here tonight
pretty good but the audience on
lofted in picking apart how the 64 year
old singer looked of course Madonna
addresses the haters head on in a
lengthy caption on Instagram quote
instead of focusing on what I said in my
speech many people chose to only talk
about the close-up photos of me taken
with a long lens camera that would
distort anyone's face
once again I am caught in the glare of
ageism and misogyny that permeates the
world we live in a world that refuses to
celebrate women past the age of 45.
Madonna adds I have never apologized for
any of the creative choices I have made
nor the way that I look or dress and I'm
not going to start people say that I'm
so controversial
but I think the most controversial thing
I have ever done is to stick around
the iconic singer ends her message with
a nod to Beyonce who've made Grammy's
history Sunday as the artist with the
most trophies quote Bow Down
[Music]
clearly Madonna brushed off the hate and
kept it moving at the Grammys after
party
[Music]
yeah Madge gives us a peek inside the
star-studded bash where she kept things
spicy even tongue-kissing jazz musician
Jazzy
I'm trying to get out of my comfort zone
but if you're a Madonna fan you know
she's a woman who proves age is nothing
but a number like when she celebrated
turning 64 last year with what else more
tongue action
and when she gave Jimmy Fallon's
audience in Eiffel on live TV
I'm sorry
[Music]